okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology
q a a history of science and technology
q
a um so we had a bunch of
questions saved up from last time
uh there's a question here
from mayday is there some particular
scientific discovery that was forgotten
and later rediscovered by someone else
whose importance
i would have liked to be recognized the
first time
oh boy the history of science is just
littered with these things um
a couple of different things that happen
i think
the main story is things get
discovered but they don't have quite
enough context
for them to become widely understood
and for them to kind of uh spread out
and get known to everybody get part of
it
it's kind of like a it's like some kind
of blockchain of knowledge or something
that do the things achieve something to
the point where they get
included in this kind of giant
blockchain or ledger
of of of the building up of knowledge or
are they things which
were sort of dropped off and people
didn't recognize
and um there are just so many examples
there are many examples from my own life
there are many examples from the history
of science
um let's let's see
well let me talk about one of them
particularly dramatic one the
antikythera device
from uh oh probably around 2000 years
ago now
um this is this mechanical computer
that was an astronomical computation
device
that uh about you know a few inches
across
um made of a bunch of
sort of fairly precise cogs and gears
and so on
intended to kind of reproduce the motion
of
of planets and so on and to be able to
to give some prediction of eclipses
things like that
this was a device that
was produced in antiquity we know
nothing about about how it was produced
where it came from
uh what was going on with it all we know
is it's in the shipwreck
of this island off the coast of greece
it was originally the lump of corroded
stuff was discovered 100 years ago
uh it was at some point dropped and
people realized oh my gosh this lump of
corroded
stuff has these cogs and gears sticking
out of it
and there was a big effort over the
course of many years even with very
recent
uh kind of uh progress
to decode what this thing actually is
and using ct scanning to look inside the
lump of corroded stuff and all this kind
of thing um
to try to figure out what it was but the
answer is what it was was
a mechanical computer the likes of which
were not seen again until the 1600s
so there was a period of about 1600
years where where this was lost and the
technology
it it wasn't the case that the
anti-cathedra device
uh it's named after the island that the
the shipwreck was found near
um it wasn't the case that this was a
unique one-off thing where
where somebody uh just sort of came up
with this
this unique thing and that was the only
one and we happen to have found it
um no i think though that there must
have been
a substantial period of development that
led to the kind of fairly elaborate
structure
that existed in this particular device
probably 50 years 100 years maybe more
than that
of development of these kinds of devices
and yet we just happened to have this
one from this one shipwreck
and nothing like it showed up again
until the 1600s
had it showed up people's understanding
i think
of the role of computation as a
foundation for understanding the world
would have been very different
um had it been something where people
routinely
expected to automate the sort of the
process of computation
the history of science would have been
different what do i mean by that
in people
this idea that you can set up the the
rules for the structure of something
and then the thing will somehow work out
the consequences of those rules
automatically
that's not a thing that we generally
know that's not a thing we
with computers now we're very used to
that idea we write a program
then the computer just on its own
autonomously runs the program and
something happens
we can see the results and we can get
this uh
something i've spent a lot of my life
doing is
getting intuition about sort of the
computational universe of programs
and what kinds of things can happen when
you just set up rules and sort of
autonomously let them run
but most of the time that's that's
really not the kind of thing people
have thought about and the fact that if
there had been
sort of computers much earlier in
history i'm sure that that would have
been a thing that would have come up
people would have said well
we just take this sort of random
collection of gearings and so on
and we say what does it do and uh
and that would get lead one down this
path of saying what does sort of
arbitrarily chosen rules
end up doing and that would have ended
up with a bunch of discoveries that i
ended up having the chance to make and
so on
so excuse me
um so the the that's an example
so the mechanical computers from
antiquity just disappeared
didn't reappear again until the 1600s i
would say that
that was one where things just didn't
sort of catch fire
there weren't enough of these things
around that the tradition
of them got got preserved um
i think that um uh there are many other
examples
of discoveries where they
were not made because there wasn't the
context to understand what one was
seeing
so for example a lot of discoveries i've
made have to do with studying this sort
of computational universe of possible
programs
and um understanding their consequences
and realizing that even when the program
is simple
the behavior it produces may be very
complicated and the question is
why weren't things like that seen before
it's a very generic very robust
phenomenon
why weren't they seen before and i went
back and looked for this and found out
that well yes there were plenty of
examples of things like that
that were seen they just didn't have a
context to be understood so for example
the digits of pi the randomness of the
digits of pi
has been known for a while for at least
200 years
it's been known that the sequence of
digits of pi 3.14159 etc
for all practical purposes looks quite
random
and yet there's definitely
a definite rule fairly simple rule that
specifies how you generate those digits
yet once generated they seem random for
example
john venn of venn diagram fame had a
book in the early 1800s i think
in which he actually plots out a random
walk
made from the digits of pi showing it
sort of randomly going around wherever
and it's like isn't that interesting
well people tried to prove things about
oh they're an equal number of ones and
zeros and so on in the digits of pi
nothing like that has ever been proved
but so
there wasn't but the people tried to
they said well yes it's random
but we don't really understand what the
significance of that is
but let's at least try and prove
something regular about the randomness
like they're an equal number of zeros
and ones
and so there wasn't really a context for
understanding so what
that the digits supply a random what
consequence does that have
how do we build that into some center
coherent narrative
coherent framework and and the same kind
of phenomenon about
sort of randomness being discovered like
the primes primes were known in
antiquity pythagoras knew about primes
for fifth century bc um plato talks
about primes
it's some uh primes were were a known
thing and people had uh
people knew about factors of numbers at
least up to the few thousands and so on
um and the fact that the sequence of
primes
looks in some ways quite random nobody
really
locked into that quest that idea it was
just like okay
it's hard to compute primes it's just
hard to compute primes
there's no significance to the fact that
these primes have a sequence that looks
kind of random
so the same thing showed up just over
and over again i mean like like for
instance
um in early simulations of neural nets
back in the
1950s people discovered that in this
you know even though they had definite
uh they sometimes they were analog but
often they were digital
simulations of these things they would
set them up they would keep them running
and sometimes they would do kind of
random things and people said
well that's just kind of a nuisance we
don't want that we want our pattern
recognition neural nets
to just recognize the pattern we don't
want it to be flapping around doing
random things
so those kinds of that discovery that
has simply set up program
whether it's for primes whether it's for
pi whether it's for the early neural
nets
whether it's for the 3n plus 1 problem
and number theory whatever
all these different cases where there
are sort of
simple rules complicated behavior it's
like there wasn't
a big thing made out of that and
you know it came i suppose to me i'm i'm
i think the
the question that was asked was are
there things where i would have liked it
if they'd been discovered earlier
uh in a sense it was fun for me that
they weren't discovered earlier because
then i got a chance to discover all this
stuff
and to realize that there was a much
bigger picture
that could be wrapped around all of
these different
examples of simple rules producing
complicated or seemingly random behavior
and
that's what led to my whole effort a new
kind of science
and the sort of the development of this
new kind of science
in which the raw material is to look at
these kind of abstract systems in the
computational universe
and see what they do and a core
phenomenon is then this phenomenon that
had precursors of which have been
observed
for hundreds of years or longer of
of this complicated behavior from simple
underlying rules
but just hadn't been put together in a
kind of intellectual
uh collection you know
i would say in my own life there have
been plenty of times when there are
things that
they should have been discovered earlier
and i just
didn't get it i didn't understand it uh
even when i was studying
uh these simple programs in the
computational universe one of my
all-time favorites rule 30
um it's a cellular automaton with just a
line of black and white cells and rules
that just say
how to determine the color of a cell
based on the color of cells
immediately adjacent to it above on the
on the on the piece of paper or whatever
well on the screen i should say these
days
well you know i first generated
rule 30 evolution back in what was it
1980 maybe
uh i think around 19 18 maybe 1981
um but for various reasons
the great significance of that of that
evolution is there's this pattern where
very simple rule you start it off in a
very simple way yet the thing it
generates
is in many respects completely random
well i first generated that probably in
1981 let's say
um and i just sort of ignored
the fact that it was possible i kind of
had arguments oh nothing like that's
going to be possible
i didn't really look at it in detail i
looked at other kinds of things with
random initial conditions and what kind
of behavior can be generated and i
came up with lots of interesting
conclusions from that but i didn't pay
attention i
i generally have a printout of rule 30
but i didn't pay attention to it then
finally i think was 1984
i had a new laser printer uh
laser printers were young and rare at
that time
and i decided i'm gonna use this laser
printer to print this really cool
picture
of all these different cellular automata
and i thought well why don't i generate
this rule 31 at very high resolution
just see what it looks like
and it's like wow this looks really
complicated what on earth is going on
here
and then i started to realize there's a
real phenomenon here
but i had to do all this build up of all
these other things that i'd looked at
before i was really ready before i was
really primed to realize
gosh there's this actual phenomenon
going on here and it's a very
powerful phenomenon and i've spent
decades after that time
uh you know exploring that phenomenon
and realizing that rule 30 is just the
tip of this giant iceberg
of all these different places where this
phenomenon occurs i mean i i view it as
being my
uh well perhaps very junior example of a
sort of the galileo 1608
moment so to speak you know in 1608
uh galileo had uh sort of
improved this sort of telescope
discovery that that um
uh he he'd heard about and had managed
to make a reasonable
astronomical telescope um the the the
myth i don't know how true this
statement is is that galileo being ever
the kind of the the opera operator of
some kind
um had licensed the use of the telescope
for terrestrial purposes
to the merchants of venice so to speak
um to
so that uh you know somebody could get
information faster than everybody else
by
running up that tower in the middle of
venice looking out on the horizon to see
whose ships were coming in
and whose ships were lost and going and
trading in the market
based on uh based on that early
information so to speak
that he'd licensed the telescope for its
terrestrial uses to those folk
but that didn't say anything about
non-terrestrial uses
and so that's why he went up to the roof
of his uh
his building and um uh you know turned
the telescope to the sky
and discovered the moons of jupiter
well you know what was surprising about
the moons of jupiter
at that time was just
you know that was something one didn't
expect to see there
one didn't expect to see what galileo i
think rather quickly interpreted as
something like a little solar system i
don't know how long it took him to
figure out
that's what he was seeing um i'm not
sure i mean his his book sidirius nazis
the um
the the starry messenger so to speak
messenger of the stars or whatever
um was uh
certainly has a discovery story about
that i don't know how um
uh how many you know i don't know
whether galileo saw
those little dots of light um near
jupiter
and said gosh those are like
like the planets orbiting the sun or
whether it took him you know how many
days weeks or whatever it took it didn't
take him that long
to figure out what was going on there
but um
in the case of looking at sort of
computational universe
the big surprise is you see something
very unexpected you see
that these simple rules produce very
complicated behavior
but to understand that you need a fa you
need
sort of a conceptual framework i suppose
for galileo he had copernicus
as his conceptual framework of this is
uh you know you can think about planets
going around a central thing
and this is and that's sort of the
priming that galileo used to understand
what he was seeing
um in his telescope and uh you know he
he he saw other kinds of things like he
saw features of the moon he saw you know
mountains on the moon and so on
and um i think in that case this sort of
interpretation of what's going on in
mountains on the moon
i'm not sure about him but certainly
other people were like well it must just
be a
you know a landscape just like on earth
and there's there's rain and there's
and there's rivers and there's all kinds
of things of course
the truth of it is that the the
mountains on the moon
have a well related but not quite the
same origin
as the topography of the earth so to
speak because there isn't an atmosphere
on the moon
so in any case i think you know a common
feature is do you have the framework do
you have the thing
that you need to understand what you see
and i think there are uh sometimes
there are discoveries quite often there
are discoveries
experiments that get done where it's
like there's this experiment and it
shows something unexpected
i think the the thing one should be
impressed by
among experimental scientists is when an
experimental scientist can deliver
something
where they say look i saw this in an
experiment and nobody expected this
and and it's right and you have to pay
attention to it
that is not the most common thing the
most common thing is very
incremental kind of well it could be
this or could be that let's do the
experiment find out which it is or
there's a theory that predicts this
let's go verify that and so on
the case that really is impressive is
when it's like
look there's this thing happening we
didn't expect this at all
but it's right and we can try to
understand what's going on
and i think um so to you know and the
point of view of experimental science
that's the kind of thing one
one looks for and i think there are
plenty of examples of where
there have been uh discoveries made
where they were not recognized for a
long time afterwards just because
maybe the experimentalist wasn't
believed maybe it wasn't trusted i i
know
for example in particle physics uh when
i was first getting into particle
physics around 1974
the big thing that was being just talked
about was the
the rise of the electron positron total
annihilation cross section
well it had been observed that rise had
been observed several years earlier
it was just like well i don't know it's
this italian
accelerator and we're not sure if it's
giving the right answer and
oh they you know and they weren't that
sure either and so on and so on and so
on
and then eventually it was sort of
enough places
a couple of places actually saw this and
it was a robust enough experiment that
yes this is real
we have to pay attention to it but you
know right now
there's uh sort of a experimental result
on the enormous magnetic moment of the
muon
where people are like oh that's not
expected you know what is the
significance of that
um i'm not sure yet um whether it's even
you know whether the experiments are
really right whether the predictions are
really right et cetera et cetera et
cetera
but um uh you know i think that's a
that's a case where
where things get interesting is when you
see something very unexpected
and you really pay attention to it um
and
the experiment is correct so to speak uh
you know there have been so many
examples in in biomedicine for example
so many examples of where people have
observed
things and um uh you know just
they weren't believed one reason or
another and then it turned out to be
true i mean i suppose one that i
i don't know all the history of is the
is the stomach ulcers
disaster where people for a long time
believed you know
certainly until fairly recent years it
was um
uh you know you are in too stressful a
job that's why you're getting stomach
ulcers
but people had known for a while that
there were theories that well it was
just an infection
and turns out that was correct but for a
long time the the force of of belief was
in one direction
that that caused that not to be the way
that um
uh the way that it was concluded i i i
suspect with this pandemic
that uh uh we still remain in in some
sense although it's
it's waning i think um the uh
there are quite a few cases where people
come up with things
where there's sort of a a some kind of
you know experimental result what's its
significance do we really take it
seriously do we not take it seriously
you know the remarkable coincidence of
infection curves
in places that did lockdowns and didn't
do lockdowns how can that possibly be
is that something significant is that a
experimental finding
that we should pay attention to that is
telling us something or is that just a
coincidence
of curves will go up and go down and so
it sort of has to be that way
um these are things where you know the
force of belief and experimental results
and whether one takes that and decides
to to build a theory around it is an
important thing
i mean i suppose in my own life another
place where this has happened
is more on the theoretical side of
trying to understand how to build a
fundamental theory of physics
and the the theory that we have now uh
is based on sort of very abstract
structures
that turn out to be extremely similar to
the abstract structures that i've used
in computational language design
for 40 years now but i didn't recognize
the fact that those structures might be
applicable
in this i although i had explored those
structures a lot might be applicable
to fundamental physics it took going
through some very circuitous route
involving other kinds of intermediate
stages to get to that point
i mean i would say the other thing that
can happen
which i think is going to happen with a
bunch of things we're discovering from
the formalism of our physics project
is okay let's say we make progress in
let's say economics
um what will end up happening is that
progress if it gets made will be made
by sort of going one step at a time from
the intuition from a formalism
to physics to intuition from physics to
sort of applying that in another place
and in the end you'll be able to say
actually you know all that stuff in the
middle about physics it's all irrelevant
we could just go straight from
this kind of formal idea to its
application in economics without going
through all this stuff in the middle
but you need that stuff in the middle as
a practical way for
for sort of us practical human
scientists so to speak
uh to be able to figure out what's going
on
all right that was a bit of a long
answer there are many things like that
to talk about okay
let's see uh
um all right there's a question here
how did the theory of computational
complexity emerge
and is there research in that field i
find particularly promising
all right what is computational
complexity theory it's very confusing
because
i developed this field that's called i
called complex systems research but
other people called complexity theory
that's kind of the theory of
systems where you have for example
simple underlying components but
complicated overall behavior
i kind of developed that
with other people who are involved also
in the 1980s
and i avoided calling that field
complexity theory
in order to avoid the pre-existing
theory
of computational complexity theory which
was about something completely different
but other people sort of started using a
name for my kind of field
that was complexity theory thereby
utterly confusing
lots of things but let me talk about
computational complexity theory
different question from um
uh complexity theory although in the end
there might be in the not too distant
future
an amazing convergence of those two sets
of ideas
but the fact that their names are
similar is not the reason for that
convergence
okay computational complexity theory
okay the question is
how hard is it to do a computation let's
say you're adding numbers together
and let's say you've got n-digit numbers
to add up two n-digit numbers
you you line up the numbers you do long
addition
it takes you the number of steps it
takes you is
roughly n steps you just gotta you know
do each digit and you know
add them up and maybe there's a carry
and you have to you have to
take account of that and that can add a
little bit more but it's roughly n steps
okay let's look at multiplication uh and
you know i'm pretty bad at doing this by
hand but with long multiplication
you write out these two numbers and you
build up this whole sort of array of
intermediate numbers
and if the numbers are each of length n
the the amount of time necessary
to the number of steps necessary to do
the multiplication
by the standard kind of uh school method
of doing multiplication
will be about n squared and so what one
says is that
that's a problem where the sort of
computational complexity of solving that
problem
is of order n squared for n digit
numbers it takes about n
squared um steps to to do the
computation
okay so the question arose given
these different kinds of computations
particularly as you made them bigger
how much more difficult would they be to
to do
so for example a very famous one is
factoring numbers if you have an
n digit number that means the number is
let's say it's binary digits that means
the number is up to
size two to the n and then the question
is how do you find the factors of that
number
well you can find the factors one way to
find the factors you just try dividing
it by numbers less than the square root
but they're of order two to the n of
those numbers uh you know two to the
other two of those numbers
so in a sense even though it was an
endless number
it's taking about two to the end steps
to do that factoring operation
and that's kind of a critical belief at
least that's made use of in public key
cryptography and the whole
infrastructure of the world
now depends on that fact that it sort of
takes two to the n
ish steps to do factoring even though
multiplying the numbers together
takes takes a time of order of order n
or n squared well okay so this question
of how difficult is it to do these
computations how
how fast can you really multiply numbers
together so
in the 1950s people
started sort of as as computers started
to get more streamlined
and people started to think about
algorithms for doing computing
people started to wonder about those
questions how difficult
is it really to do stuff so an example
sorting things if you have n things to
sort how do you sort them well
you've got them all in line and you can
just say let me compare
each two that i see next to each other
if they're in order leave them the way
they are if they're out of order flip
them around
that's a particular strategy for sorting
the question is
that's an n squared sorting algorithm
with n objects it takes
n squared comparisons on on average to
sort the list
how how fast can you sort so um
in the 1960s i think early 1960s
for example a chat called tony horror
invented a thing
called the quick sort uh which is a
kind of a weird recursive algorithm for
sorting things where you sort of break
breaks the sequence in two and you sort
each subsequence and then you combine
them together
it's a sort of recursive tree-like
algorithm and it sorts in about n log n
time
so that was an early kind of surprise
algorithm
where things work faster than you would
expect even for multiplication
you might say well it takes n squared
steps well it doesn't actually
because a lot of the things you're doing
are repeats of things you've done before
and so pretty quickly it was discovered
how to do it in a i think end of the
1.58
up uh steps and then gradually it was
discovered how to do it
in uh about n log n or n log log n
uh steps but that was those things were
discovered in the 1960s there was a lot
of work
done there's a lot of soviet work done
on these kinds of things i suppose one
can
one could imagine that well computers
were harder to make there so
it took was worth spending the human
effort to try and optimize the
algorithms
um a thing that happened um was
uh but that wasn't yet
a coherent field of kind of exploring
sort of the complexity in quotes in the
sense of this difficulty of doing
algorithms it was just a
a one-off thing and and in the 1960s a
lot of work got done on linear algebra
on matrix computations
all these different algorithms about
these different kinds of decomposition
and so on
all these different progressively more
algorithms got discovered for
that where people worried about how fast
is this algorithm
and would it be an n log n algorithm or
an n squared algorithm what kind of
thing would it be
okay so then the question was there was
sort of a
thing noticed that there were these
classes of algorithms there were these
things where
uh if you could do one of them well you
it was sort of like doing another one
and there were sort of things that
came together one one class of of cases
where things like the factoring problem
where you've got a number and you say
work out its prime factors well that's
hard to do it might take
exponential time to the n steps to the n
computations to do that
but multiplying those numbers together
to check that they are indeed the
factors of that number that's very fast
so this idea that there might be
computations which are
if you could guess the answer if you
somehow got the answer
they're very fast to check but it may be
hard to systematically get the answer
that class of questions people sort of
started recognizing
in the 1960s that there were a bunch of
of questions that were like that
and that related to the idea of
non-deterministic turing machines turing
machines where
there are many possible sort of
computations the turing machine could do
and you say you're a winner if there
exists
a possible computer a possible path of
computation
that gets you to the answer even if
there are others that go off and do
crazy things
so non-deterministic turing machines uh
they were kind of um in the 1950s those
started to be investigated
and it started to be there started to be
results on whether a non-deterministic
turing machine
could do more than an ordinary machine
it can't because you can always just
enumerate although it might take
exponentially many steps
the non-deterministic turing machines
different paths and so on there were
results about tilings whether you could
uh you know tile the plane with tiles of
a certain form
that was shown to be equivalent to the
halting problem for non-deterministic
touring machines by how wang
that must have been in the round uh
late 1950s early 1960s but
um actually kurt godel um has some
letter somewhere where he talks about
this phenomenon
of this kind of um things that can be
checked quickly but are hard to
systematically find out like this
factoring problem
okay so the big setup then was
uh what in going towards the end of the
1960s
um the the kind of the
the classification of these different
kinds of problems so
a big class of problems which became
called the class of p
problems polynomial time problems were
ones where
as you make the size of the problem
instance bigger the n
bigger the amount of computational work
the amount of the number of
computational steps increases like a
polynomial in n
so it might be n squared it might be n
cubed it might be n to the 1.5
but it's a polynomial in n as opposed to
an exponential a two to the n
you know more rapid increase so so it
sort of became the case in the 1960s
that that um
there was a um uh the sort of class of
problems that were polynomial time
and then there were the class of
problems that were np non-deterministic
polynomial time
if you could get the answer somehow by
guessing it or some other way
then you could uh then you could then
you could check the answer in polynomial
time
okay so then the thing that happened in
1970 stephen cook
um uh developed this idea of mp
completeness
so that idea so so
the thing was there were these problems
that were np
problems there were a bunch that were
known there were problems
like uh factoring there were problems
like
uh satisfiability given a boolean
expression
uh you know p or q and not r and
uh p whatever given that boolean
expression
are there assignments of true false
truth values to p
q etc such that that expression can be
true
another example of an np problem once
you've got such an assignment truth
values
it's very fast to check whether in fact
the expression is true
but to find out whether there is such an
assignment of truth values
in principle you might have to try all
to the end possibilities
there were various kinds of graph
matching problems there were problems in
in parsing there were problems in all
kinds of different combinatorial
problems
which seemed to be in this class np and
and nobody knew how to do any of them
quickly nobody knew how to do any of
them polynomial time
so what stephen cook realized is that
there's a notion of mp completeness
that is that in a sense there are
problems in the class np
which have the property that any other
problem in the class np
can be encoded in polynomial time in
terms of that problem
so it's like universal computers you
know universal computers
you know understood in the turing
machine times and so on in 1936
by the way we talked earlier about about
discoveries that were not made
that could have been made earlier the
very idea of universal computation
could easily have been made earlier than
1936
and it had precursors and girls thurman
had because in combinators from 1920
it had precursors and leibniz's work in
the 1600s
but it wasn't made until there was the
sort of co
you know until the framework existed and
there's a sort of
critical mass of of of things that came
together
but any case the um the the idea of
universal computers
is there can be a fixed universal
computer a fixed universal turing
machine
where just by changing its programming
it can do any computation you want
well that's true for computations what
stephen cook
looked at in np problems is this idea of
mp completeness where you can have
one np problem that has the property
that
by setting it up appropriately with an
appropriate instance of that np problem
you can encode any other mp problem so
for example satisfiability
was was i think the first one where that
was established
where you could show that satisfiability
could encode
these graph matching problems it could
encode other kinds of things
you could use it like a junior version
of a universal computer
uh junior in a sense that it could
encode all these other mp problems
and it could do it where the encoding
needed was a polynomial time encoding
okay so that was this idea of mp
completeness and
that was a powerful idea because that
meant that if you had mp completeness
then
if you could show that satisfiability
could be done in polynomial time
then every other mp problem could also
be done in polynomial time
so it means that there are the these
sort of hardest problems
the the um the sort of the maximally
difficult problems in the in the class
np
are these mp complete problems and there
are many of them my principle of
computational equivalence kind of
suggests that there will be
they'll be quite ubiquitous in the space
of mp problems but that's a
that's a different issue but um
okay so anyway in 1970 this
idea of mp completeness arose uh
people uh there was a famous book by
gary and johnson
that was sort of a a catalog of uh of np
complete problems
that kind of just showed how broad this
idea of mp completeness was because so
many different popular problems
all turned out to be np complete well
then they're developed other forms of
computational complexity so you can say
well np completeness is about the amount
of time it takes
there's also the notion of p space how
much memory
do you need a polynomially increasing
amount of memory to do this
there were for a while the main
computational complexity classes were p
and np and p
space then as people started to think
about parallel computation this is now
more in the uh probably in the 19
what was that 19 late mid to late 1980s
people started talking about um uh
classes of
computational complexity classes that
involve doing things on parallel
computers
um where you could have many computers
running in parallel
and you say how long does it take how
many computers does it need and so on
and eventually there became this whole
zoo of different computational
complexity classes
and one started to know things like is
is
p strictly a subset of np or does p
equal np
and that's that's a sort of famous
problem of is there in fact a polynomial
time way to do
uh uh to do these problems um
so that for a while
people were like p versus np that's you
know a key problem
that's something that um uh we really
you know it's it's really a defining
problem of computation
and and you know the question then is
when you have a problem that is mp
complete
does that mean that if you if if
suddenly something you're studying
is mp complete does that mean game over
your toast
you'll never be able to do it it's going
to take too long well not in practice
because many mp problems even mp
complete problems
have the feature that there are
approximate solutions that are very good
that can be found quite quickly
and it's only just there's maybe one
really really good solution
but it's better than all the others and
there's this question sort of what's the
distribution is it a is it a thing where
the best solutions are over here in this
tail uh you know a
sort of a separate little little colony
far away from the tail is there sort of
a continuous variation where
if you do reasonably well you can get
into the tail and so there were methods
like simulated annealing
so it's a one place where mp complete
problems show up quite often
is in circuit layout where you're asking
is there a way of laying out all these
components
so that you minimize the wire length for
something like this
um and uh and then the question was you
could as you try to do that
you very quickly if you say well i'm
going to take this
this configuration i'm going to just
gradually tweak it i'm going to kind of
evolve it gradually
to something where it is correct well
you might get stuck you might have a
configuration where
there's no way by incremental changes to
get it to the best solution
is something that happens in many
systems this sort of idea of sort of
local minimum happens a lot in machine
learning and things like that
where where you kind of get stuck this
incremental process
um gets gets kind of stuck and you have
to kind of um
uh be be much wilder in your thinking so
to speak
it's kind of like the way people think
about things you know you can end up in
a very definite path
and you don't figure things out but you
have to have something from way
out you know the sort of lateral
thinking from from somewhere completely
different
that comes in and shows you the answer
so there was a method uh i think scott
patrick was the main person involved in
this
who developed um at ibm in the
1970s developed this method called
simulated annealing
so in annealing in a metal for example
you're trying to get a nice
crystalline metal um you you know the
the grains of the metal might have all
lined up in a particular direction but
they may be in multiple different grains
in the metal you can anneal it you can
heat it up again
and then cool it down again and as you
as you do that you're you're
you're unfreezing the the kind of
configuration
and you're letting it sort of re-freeze
again and so
so similar to annealing was a method
that was developed to find approximate
solutions
to things like np problems with some
degree of success
so so it isn't the case and in fact in
wolfram language and mathematica there
are many things that we do
where in principle the problem is mp
complete but in practice we can solve it
uh for all practical purposes really
quickly um
for example the travelling salesman
problem the problem if you've got a
bunch of cities in different places
and so on you're asked what's a route
that visits those cities and the order
so that the total distance that you will
have to go in visiting all those cities
is the smallest
so that is an mp complete problem but in
fact
in morphing language we have a function
called find shortest tour
up to thousands of of cities it will do
a very good job
of getting you uh if not the absolutely
best
a very close to the best routing around
those cities
okay so you know what's happened with
computational complexity theory well so
the p versus np
problem has been still an outstanding
problem
you know when arthur jaffe made up these
clay millennial problems a few years ago
uh somebody put you know put a million
dollar bounty
on this p versus np problem um it sort
of got
cast into a slightly different light
when uh
peter shaw um uh
realized that quantum turing machines as
opposed to ordinary turing machines
quantum turing machines that sort of are
models of of quantum mechanics
could solve the factoring problem in
something that seemed like polynomial
time the end of that story is not
completely told and our physics project
kind of shows that there are some issues
with that and their issues about how the
effectively the quantum measurement
process
works all kinds of things like that but
that was an excitement of the 1990s was
it
um that sort of helped launch the whole
quantum computing
idea uh well it had been launched back
in the 1980s and things
but sort of helped get to get energy
behind it
was this idea well maybe we'll be able
to do factoring
uh in in polynomial time on a quantum
computer
now this is all a bit tricky because
factoring is not
known to be an mp complete problem it is
known to be
an np hard problem which is it's in the
class np
and it's it has various characteristics
but it's not
a problem where it's known that oh we
solve this we've broken all the other mp
complete problems
and it's not completely clear what the
whole story of quantum computers is
for that anyway but that's a place where
there's a whole nother
raft of kind of work in quantum
complexity for computational complexity
theory
that ask for a quantum turing machine as
opposed to a turing machine
or a non-deterministic turing machine
how fast can you do these computations
well my own feeling is this question p
versus np
you know rnp problems doable in
polynomial time
it's actually a pretty difficult
question to not
even to define it might seem like an
obvious question but
let's say that you have a specific
algorithm specific turning machine
specific
program whatever and you say here's my
program for solving this particular
problem
okay you could imagine enumerating all
possible programs
just asking what's the best one for
solving this size
n instance of the satisfiability problem
okay
we get the answer we know it's this
particular program
then we go to the next size we say
what's the very best program for solving
this satisfiability problem of this size
probably it's a different program
so what you have to ask is it becomes a
pretty difficult
thing that sort of a mixture of
enumerating possible programs
and looking at their their running times
um as a function of size and then you
have to start enumerating all possible
problem instances and so on
so a question is as you look at that in
the infinite limit and you say which is
going to win
my collection of programs that i've been
enumerating or
the polynomial the sort of the line that
says this is the limit
of polynomial time or something else
and that question of who's going to win
is a very complicated question
that is not just difficult in terms of
the mathematics of
of setting up possible programs and
analyzing them and so on it's even
difficult to define what you mean
because it can wiggle around a lot
and my own suspicion is that the p
versus mp problem
as it is you know it seems like an
obvious definition but it's not really
quite as obvious
and it's not obvious that there will be
an answer so so
given a particular axiom system that
you're operating within you can say
can that axiom system answer the
question of what happens in the end for
infinite n
what happens and the problem is it's
like many of these kinds of things there
are there are questions about
does this sequence ever terminate well
it may be the case
that there is an axiom system like the
axioms of arithmetic the piano axioms or
the axis of set theory cfc axioms
whatever
those axioms just aren't powerful enough
to answer that question
that in some sense is an answer well
it's hard to say is there an answer it's
it's some
uh you know there's no upper bound on
how long it may take you to answer that
question
and the question would be is there with
a finite set of axioms
can you say i'm just going to grab the
answer it may be arbitrarily far out it
may take me an arbitrarily long time in
general
but i'm going to use these axioms to
just sort of jump ahead and grab the
answer
well it may be which is what you're
trying to do when you're saying i'm
going to solve the p versus empty
problem
it's saying i'm going to take the piano
axioms and i'm going to say
slam dunk i've i've solved the p versus
mp problem
as opposed to i have to keep going i
have to look at more cases i have to
do this i have to do that i have to do
the other thing i i can't figure it out
finitely or is it the case that i can
sort of finitely
go and just take the the axioms of sap
theory or something
just say okay i got the answer my guess
is it's going to be independent of some
of these axiom systems i don't know
whether the independent
of set theory um it uh i would be
quite likely it's independent of pianos
axioms
and those different axiom systems they
involve different kinds of induction
different kinds of mathematical
induction that they support
things like that so that's a that's sort
of a
that's that's the but people are mostly
mostly people think the p versus mp
problem is just kind of too hard
and they're looking at it i think there
are ways into it using essentially
empirical computational complexity
theory i've done some of this
um i will say that i think in general in
the understanding of p vs mp and so on
and let me not talk about this in detail
here
i think that some of the things that
we've understood from our physics
project particularly about these things
called rule multi-rate systems
uh basically speak to many of these
issues about p versus mp and so on
and i think there is a way of
geometrizing essentially
computational space that in the end is
going to turn out
to tell one a whole lot about these
computational complexity kinds of
questions basically the issue is we've
got all these different programs
okay so let's say you have numbers you
know 1 1.1 one point whatever
numbers very easy to arrange them on a
line it's very easy to give geometry to
numbers
you can just sort of say how they how
they arrange themselves
um in the case of programs it's much
less clear how that works you've got
this program it does this you've got
that program it does that
how do those programs how do you arrange
those programs in some sort of
geometrical space well that's something
i think we're understanding
on the basis of um of um physics models
and also on the basis of things that
come from
ideas from higher category theory and so
on i think we're understanding the
answer to that and that geometrization
of computational complexity theory i
think is going to lead to some really
interesting results
but this is a this is a about history
that's about the future so i've tried to
give you a summary a little bit of the
history of computational complexity
theory
and um uh it's been very difficult you
know computational complexity theory
uh one of the biggest challenges is to
find a lower bound on a computation
to say this computation can never be
done faster than this
for example when it comes to multiplying
numbers you'll never be able to do it
faster than a time of order n because
that's the time it takes to just read
the digits and the number
you'd never know what the answer was
without at least reading all the digits
but there are very few lower bounds that
have been found
on on different on computations there
are a few film with boolean algebra
um but that's that's the sort of holy
grail of computational complexity theory
is to prove
lower bounds on how difficult it is to
do a computation
um okay
let's see
uh well let me take just a couple more
things here um
there's a question here i don't know all
the details of this there's a question
here from brian
has the voynich manuscript ever been
decoded
um you know there was a big tradition
i think in the 1600s particularly of
writing these kind of obscure
ciphers writing books in some kind of
obscure cipher that only
only some particular group would
understand
and sometimes people wondered you know
maybe some of these books were just
nonsense
they were just generated by coin
flipping and there was nothing you know
you could try and figure them out
but you'd never figure them out i mean
it's been sort of a tradition for a long
time and people
you know the puzzle being set up but
that was a particular thing
a particular period of time and um
the uh um
the thing that um
was with that there are these kind of
these kind of cases where
where people have um have written these
encoded documents and the question is
do they mean anything do they mean
nothing
how would you decode them if they meant
something it's sort of an interesting
thing that's kind of like
extraterrestrial intelligence or like
archaeology
it's like you've got this thing what
does it mean does it mean anything
you know you've got these marks on a
stone do they mean something
or are they somebody just playing around
and testing out their chisel or
what what was going on here it's very
hard to answer in general
i think what tends to happen in the
decoding of things whether it's some
uh you know hieroglyphics linear b
whatever whatever all these different
kinds of things
um you know what tends to happen is that
there's a sequence of stepping stones
that uh you know you have to find a sort
of rosetta stone
that connects these two languages or you
have to find a way
in which you can find something which is
close to that language and then get to
this one and so on
there was the thing was done recently
there was some
some nasty um a set of crimes in
california i guess
that uh uh the the that went under the
heading of the zodiac
killer who had i think sent to some
newspapers these kind of
encoded messages
and for many years maybe close to 50
years perhaps
these messages have been undecoded and
just in the last few months
a chap called sam blake former employee
of ours actually
and i think some other people also were
successful in using
wolfram language and mathematica to uh
to decode those algorithms to decode
those messages
and find out the um uh
rather rather chilling actually uh final
sort of messages from
from this particular uh serial murderer
um uh about that um that this person had
sent in finally
was possible to decode those but it took
a long time to um
and there was sort of a bunch of new
ideas about how to kind of decode
a certain kind of uh kind of cipher and
and as i said it's hard to know if there
is a decoding
um and you just haven't been sort of
smart enough to figure out what it is
or if there really isn't a decoding and
the thing is what one might call a fake
it's just found by by coin filtering for
example
all right let's see um
oh my gosh
um
well there's some questions here about
piva sempi
um
does a proof not exist to show that np
cannot be done in p
is that the way to solve the p vs mp
problem assuming
appears a subset of np
well the issue is if the set of
polynomial
the set of polynomial time problems is
obviously
a subset of the set of
non-deterministic polynomial time
problems the question is is it
a proper subset in the sense that there
exists
things in np that are not in p that is
problems that are doable as a
non-deterministic polynomial time
computation but not doable as a
polynomial time computation
that's the key issue whether whether p
is equal to np or whether there are
pieces of np that are missing from p
it's it's certainly known that p
is that that anything that's in np is
certainly also in p
um there's a question here
from the i i guess could a computer
randomly generate
and test all algorithms from uh
graphical possibilities
um yeah so i mean the question of can
you find an algorithm
that is a polynomial time algorithm
that is okay let me give you an example
the sorting problem so you've got these
n things and you've got to compare them
and you're doing binary comparisons
and you're asking how many binary
comparisons do you have to do to sort
n things okay so for a particular value
of n
like 10 is it known for 10 yes it's
known for 10.
um it's known what the fastest algorithm
the
smallest number of of comparisons that
have to be done
is in what order they have to be done so
it's an interesting fact
that as you just try to enumerate all
possible algorithms for doing that
the one that's the winner is one that
looks quite complicated
and it's known up to size maybe 14 or
something
i don't know there's a bunch of pictures
of this in the encased book i i'd have
to look it up
um but you know once just trying
different algorithms and ones saying
is there a faster algorithm you know
what's the fastest you just enumerate
all the possible
sorting algorithms you just say what's
the fastest algorithm to sort 11 things
into order
and but there's no regularity it's not
like the thing that's the fastest for 11
things
immediately gives you a way to get the
fastest for 12 things
each one of those is a sort of custom
fastest
for a particular value of n and so one
of the challenges in the p versus mp
question
is how do you get the sort of flight of
results which will be valid for all n
that's one of the one of the complicated
issues to figure out and people haven't
done much of this empirical
computational complexity theory
where you're just saying what is the
fastest thing that you can get
for for a particular size i mean i
looked at this in the case of
combinators i looked at it recently
um at what the shortest combinator
that generates particular things is for
for a succession of sizes
and that gives you sort of an empirical
version of computational complexity
theory
and potentially gives you intuition
about how the general problem of
of infinite size works
um all right maybe one or two others
here
um
okay it's a question from g sup about vr
virtual reality
well this is going to be a combination
of history in the future i suppose to
talk about this so what is virtual
reality
virtual reality is the ability
to have a sort of a a perception of the
world
that seems close to reality
in the sense that and so what this
actually turns into is you wear these
goggles
and they give you a 3d kind of
perception of the world and as you turn
your head there are
their accelerometers and the goggles and
they you know as you
normally if i turn my head i'll see
different things and
when you're looking through these vr
goggles as you turn your head they'll
show you different
stuff just like just as if you were
there so to speak
well sort of in the in the big sort of
arc of history
there's kind of when did things get to
the point where
it's as good as if you were there audio
got to that point by the 1990s basically
you know you can put little you know
things things in your ears
and the the you know with 44 kilohertz
of sampling of sounds you are you're at
the point where
it's it's sort of as good as it would be
if you were in that concert hall more or
less you're
the thing that is getting into your
sensory system is just the same
as it would be in the concert hall so to
speak for vision that hasn't yet
happened
it's getting closer and virtual reality
is part of the story of making that
happen we have a lot more nerve fibers
going through our optic nerves than
going we have maybe 10 million in our
optic nerve
maybe 50 000 in our auditory nerve so
it's sort of not surprising it's more
complicated more data
that's involved in getting it to sort of
getting us to have
as if you were their visual experiences
than as if you were their audio
experiences
but it's gradually been working to be to
be closer to that
and um the you know historically
what happened is that well back
around the late 1980s there was a big
sort of uh
um big sort of puff of interest in
virtual reality and i remember
being at a siggraph conference must have
been 1989 or so
and there was sort of a lot of
excitement for virtual reality it's like
try this on
you can you know you can play tennis in
virtual reality
and the use cases in those days were
things like playing tennis and virtual
reality
architectural walkthroughs somebody's
going to build a big building and
they're going to spend millions of
dollars on it
and it's like what's it going to be like
to be in this space well let's build a
3d model
and let's experience it in virtual
reality
then um uh what was the other case the
other another case was um
uh molecular modeling there's a time
when rational drug design was big
and people were saying let's try and
visualize this molecule in 3d and you
can
kind of use it with your hands to kind
of you know one of the issues that sort
of not really virtual reality but it's a
related thing
is when you're making a 3d object it's
really a big big pain
to actually construct 3d things and so
one thing that people have long wanted
is a kind of clay-like experience
everyone's getting closer to this
we can just use your fingers to kind of
mold the 3d object
rather than having to say oh you know
align this plane here and you turn
things around you put this other
surface there and so on it's all very
very awkward and very sort of
sequentialized being able to do it
in this kind of uh moldable way is is
something which is not quite the virtual
reality story but it's
so relatable anyway so there's this sort
of puff of interest
in um in the late 1980s and uh there
have been
as a chap called jaren lanier who was
very involved in
in creating the the early virtual
reality systems
kind of came out of um uh well his
he had this glove that had a very very
bizarre origin
um but uh that was um
uh for sort of sensing um
uh sensing sensing um uh sort of finger
positions and things
and um then um uh there were
um um kind of
um uh you know that sort of went along
with
the the as if reality you know the the
headdress
and all that kind of stuff so
so for a long time things really okay so
so like at my company we started
developing things for vr
back in the in the um in the early 1990s
and um uh well it all didn't it all kind
of petered out
didn't really work out it wasn't really
a thing it wasn't the systems weren't
good enough
you know even now i i tend to get motion
sick when i
use a vr system because somehow the you
know the
the things in my ears that sense
acceleration and orientation for me
don't quite align with the things i'm
seeing in my eyes and
and so on and so on and so on it's
getting progressively better
but um not quite there yet um but uh
and we definitely weren't there in the
in the um at the beginning of the 1990s
so i think uh
uh the the other thing that happened
sort of historically so
so that then then the big thing that
happened was was five years ago maybe a
little bit more than that
um there was this one of the challenges
in vr
is just as you're looking through these
screens you have little little monitors
near your eyes and you know it's a
head-mounted display that was kind of
the big big thing about some back in the
in the late 1980s the notion of
head-mounted displays and that had been
a thing that was was done
a bunch of military applications for
that and so on
but but so the the um the the kind of
uh uh this notion of the the
head-mounted display
um where you know you turn your head and
it shows you different things and so on
um that um well let's see so
so uh
that had had well one of the issues is
when you have that head mounted display
how
accurate is this kind of visual scene
that you see and one of the issues is
if all you see are these little monitors
that just
uh you know go to a certain angle around
your eyes
it isn't very realistic because like
well i can see the edge of the monitor
that's not real life
because in reality we have pretty decent
peripheral vision you know i'm
i'm waving my hand off here and you know
i can still sense that there's something
waving there
even though that's that's uh you know
that's a long way away from the
direction of my eye
um and you know we have our retinas have
have um
uh you know a bunch of cells on them go
round to a pretty large angle so one of
the one of the innovations
that uh for example oculus um was uh
was into was making a fairly cheap
well sort of set up displays that had a
large opening angle
um so that was that was one of the other
that was one of the things i think it
was about five years ago now
um sort of a burst of interest around um
oculus and
and other and other things sort of
another issue for virtual reality
is okay so that was that was one thing
was the virtual reality story
the other story was the augmented
reality story
which is you put something in front of
your visual scene
where you're seeing the ordinary visual
scene but you're annotating it somehow
and then the question was can you mount
can you have a reasonable head-mounted
thing
that is able to give you
a a good perception of something in your
visual field
and you could either have that as
something in your glasses you can have a
laser that's
that's sort of you know painting things
on the back of your eye there are a
bunch of different schemes
for doing that and there's been a
certain degree of enthusiasm for that
the google glass project was a
was a big sort of puff of enthusiasm for
that where the idea was
you know you i mean i have some of these
things you you have this little
you have this thing where there's a a
sort of a
a piece of glass where there's sort of a
projector that's projecting
uh light into that piece of glass which
is then
uh with total internal reflection is is
sending it back to your eye
and that's so it's superimposing this
kind of
data in front of your visual field and
um
the uh i think the thing that and that
was when was that when was google glass
i don't know i'm losing track of time
five years ago maybe
uh some no it was it was longer ago than
that it was um
it must have been nearly ten years ago
nine years ago because i remember
i remember i was thinking about for
quite other reasons i was thinking about
the problem of the algorithmic problem
of annotating visual scenes like if
you're gonna put labels on the visual
scene that i'm looking at right now
where do i put the labels because i
don't want to put them right in on top
of somebody's face i want to put them
out of the way you have to have some
kind of saliency filter
that figures out where the uninteresting
parts of the image so that's where you
get to put the labels
and so on it'll be a um okay so anyway
there was sort of an enthusiasm for
for augmented reality um around google
glass that must have been as i say
close to 10 years ago now um as is
always the case in the world of
technology these things eventually come
back it's kind of like the fax machine
it was invented 100 years before you
know it became popular and
you know gradually things come back so
one of the things that sort of held up i
think one of the issues is
you've got a vr system and what's the
operating system what's the you know
we've got
one of the reasons that bitmap displays
and terminals and so on
became pretty common is you know
operating systems know how to deal with
them um
the question of of what to do with
virtual reality
and how to represent that visual scene
and the interactions with it
and for example things like unity i
guess unreal engine
things like this um these these systems
for uh that are essentially game engines
um these are the things that have become
so the de facto standard
for representing geometry in a way that
can be used for virtual reality but it's
a very bizarre sort of heavyweight
mechanism because they are representing
both the geometry
and all the sort of game actions that
can be done with that geometry you
really only need to represent the
geometry
but there hasn't been a very clear
standard that's emerged for how to do
that
so you know it's a bit unclear what's
going to happen i mean
for example you know it's funny when i
was
first starting to think about these kind
of discrete models of space time
back in the early 1990s that was at a
time when virtual reality was big and i
kind of imagined that i would have these
giant networks
and i would be able to be inside the
cobwebs so to speak
and use my fingers to kind of move the
cobweb around
and get it to the point where i could
sort of visualize what was happening in
this kind of giant evolving network
okay so we're now in 2021 we're now 30
years later
and um uh yes i'm i'm thinking about
that again you know a year or so ago
i had made a few of these uh complicated
networks
in in virtual reality and tried to
understand them in virtual reality
i have to say it was kind of a funny
thing because it's like i don't expect
in my line of work
that computer experimentation has sort
of occupational hazard
type type things associated with it but
i was finding that i was trying to use
this
and i was finding that i go into vr i
visualize some of these universes
and pretty soon i get motion sick and
it's kind of like i can only do it for a
small number of minutes
before i you know before i get motion
sick and can't can't do this anymore
um one of my kids actually gave me some
one of these
many motions uh sickness uh
uh strange sort of acupunctural uh kind
of
uh avoid motion sickness things uh to to
help my kind of occupational hazard
of um uh of of living in virtual reality
to do
doing science in virtual reality it's
very exotic you know it's it's somehow
one doesn't expect to sort of put on
gear to be going to investigate the
fundamental theory of physics at least
not a theoretical
point of view um but any case so that
wasn't a great success now we're
we're trying again to do something where
we have a big gpu-based
system using this vulcan language um
to uh to sort of do the hypograph
evolution
and to be able to sort of present that
in in vr
we'll see how that works i think the big
issue with ar
augmented reality and sometimes people
talk about xr the kind of domination
vr ar uh thing
ar i think has the potential to be
pretty interesting
you know if if i'm going around and not
that i've done that for the last year
but um sort of out and about in the
world and you're meeting groups of
people and it's like
okay let's annotate this person you know
when you're in zoom it's very easy to
annotate who is that person
you just hover over them and it gives
the name but um in real life
we're not used to being able to sort of
uh
uh just sort of look at that person and
immediately a little bubble comes up
that says
who that person is and you know tells
you what all the email transactions
you've had with that person
in the last 20 years or whatever else it
is um
the uh uh you know that's something that
augmented reality potentially can bring
the difficulty is how do you make
glasses that are
uh you know how do you make something
lightweight enough people can really
wear on their heads
how do you make it so you don't have a
giant sort of computer in your back
pocket so to speak
you know i've i've used a few of these
systems um that
are very promising in terms of the the
optics of how they deliver the images
but they're just like you've got to wear
this giant thing on your head
or you've got to strap to your you know
uh
to yourself this this big um you know
powerful computer and so on so
so these are these are practical
problems i mean the the rumor is that
apple is working on sort of an ar
uh system um and uh perhaps they'll
manage to come up with something that is
as
sort of impressive as the air pods or
something in terms of just a sort of a
form factor of how to deliver it
once it's delivered and once it really
becomes a thing i i
i suspect there'll be all kinds of
things i mean there'll be a question of
whether there's a camera
also able to look at the scene that
you're seeing because if there is
and you can then do a kind of analysis
of the scene there's all kinds of things
you can do
you know you can do things like visual
diffs i'm walking into this room again
what's changed here
oh my ar system will annotate that for
me i mean the case
of being out and about and sort of
recognize the face well
who knows whether that will be you know
what what the future sort of face
recognition is going to be but
assuming you could do that you could um
and maybe the answer is you're not
actually recognizing the face
it's just some kind of bluetooth
communication with the person's phone
and it knows oh that's the person there
but then it's annotating in your visual
field it's saying
that so and so and oh you guys are both
interested in this you should talk about
that
um there are also many kinds of things
like material identification
or things like infrared where you say
that thing is really hot
don't touch it and you can tell that by
the fact that you can see it's infrared
emission
but you couldn't see that by just
looking at it visually but your ar
system
can target for that and there's a whole
list of these things i realize it's now
nearly 10 years ago but i
i made this big list of ar applications
and i was trying to figure out
sort of how how one would actually
deploy those things in welfare language
and we came up with a lot of very
interesting things
and did absolutely nothing with them
because the hardware just didn't
didn't make it um and uh
so that that that that's what happened
to that um
okay brian is saying a cool vr site
would be a digital louvre where you
enter
and walk around looking at nfts and
other types of exhibits
that is actually an interesting idea so
so i just went to
a um on uh when was it friday night or
something i went to a
a virtual gallery opening in virtual
reality
of a gallery opening of ai artists
so it's um so in other words this is
something this was using the high
fidelity
platform for um virtual gatherings
um and it wasn't uh wasn't a
full uh you know head head-mounted
display experience
um just a uh sort of an audio
3d audio experience plus video um
of wandering around chatting with people
looking at artworks
produced by by ai artists
using uh um i guess scan type technology
with the artist statements generated by
gtbt3
with them just pure
synthesized text and so on uh but there
were real humans there
which was fun but um yeah so so but this
idea oh and by the way of course every
piece of art that was there was
some of it was already in nfts and some
of it was about to be auctioned
as nfts and so on um and um
for those who don't know nfts are
non-fungible tokens
is kind of the idea on blockchain most
popularly ethereum right now but tezos
and and other blockchains are getting
these two
um the idea is to have this token that
says
i own this thing just like in a
you know title deeds of a house there's
a thing that says you know i own this
house
and it's stored at the title registry so
here on the ethereum blockchain is
something for all to see
saying this this address
owns this particular token and there's
this erc20
token protocol that well this um
this is a a type of computational
contract
that basically says only one person can
own
this token so if i own this nft
the only way you get to own this nft is
if i transfer this nft to you
you can't clone the nft because there's
a unique copy of it
um on this uh on this blockchain so
so the one of the coming attractions in
the world of
of art is let's make that into an nft
and yeah we're we're doing some of these
things too although i really want trying
to figure out a really clever thing to
do with nfts which we may or may not
succeed in in finding um but uh and
it's unclear whether nfts are relevant
to things like software licensing
all kinds of interesting things like
that um but
um uh yes the the notion of
you can go around and um i mean it's a
very bizarre thing
the louvre you know you could um uh you
too
could own an nft for the mona lisa but
presumably you're not the sole
owner of the nft for the mona lisa
because there has to be this connection
between the physicality of the mona lisa
and the number of nfts that have been
created for it
and it's kind of like the the concept of
you know when you have a
a limited edition porcelain pig or
something
um you know at some point it's a limited
edition because the mold was broken
and there are no more uh you know no
more
well no more coins or whatever in some
mint no more coins are going to be
produced of that exact kind
because the mold was broken and so you
know there are only that number of coins
in circulation
in the physical world those coins are
not cloneable
at least not without you know more
elaborate 3d scanner 3d printer type
technology
all right i think i need to wrap up here
um and
uh lots of interesting questions for
another time
and uh we've explored a variety of
different
um uh different kinds of things um
and uh yeah very interesting stuff um
actually for those interested i'm doing
a a live stream associated with my day
job in just a few minutes about
uh language design for language but um
i have to go from here now so uh thanks
for joining us
and come back another time and